we live in an age of technological
marvels and these are constantly
changing urban life and changing cities
twenty years ago no one had a single
Facebook friend and no one could reap a
lousy service with a bad yelp review now
urban revolutions are guided by Twitter
in this section we're going to explore
how technology is changing cities and
how cities are changing technology for
most of human history technology moved
at a pretty glacial pace
one farmer owed and reaped pretty much
the same way that his grandfather did
when technological change did occur it
tended to be in cities where incremental
improvements in urban tasks like weaving
would occasionally emerge but then in
the late 18th century things started to
change first machines revolutionize
cloth manufacturing then James Watts
separate condenser steam engines brought
power to factories into cities into
transportation and then the trickle of
innovation became a torrent cars and
radios and air conditioners and
television sets all radically changed
the way humanity lived they also enabled
and changed cities try imagining the
rise of Sun Belt metropolis is like
Atlanta without the air-conditioner the
first question for this section is how
do cities enable technological change if
new ideas come from combining old ideas
does the diversity of old ideas in
cities make innovation easier as Jane
Jacobs once argued does urban scale make
it easier to find a market for new
innovations do new ideas spread more
easily in cities or have these forces
become irrelevant in the Internet age
the second big question is how will
future technological change impact
cities self-driving cars maybe uber in
the air a more user-friendly version of
Twitter some of these technologies may
improve urban life others may just
exacerbate old city woes autonomous
vehicles could easily lead to a lot more
driving which might only make urban
traffic worse the final question
concerns the interplay between
technology and urban government some
governments have tried to use technology
to improve the delivery of city services
others have tried to regulate innovation
and entrepreneurship more generally how
considers balance the benefits and costs
of change we can be sure that technology
will continue to mold urban life but I'm
less sure that we'll know exactly how to
get the most out of that technology
you